I'm very happy to be back at Yale some
of you I haven't seen since the birthday
party in 2003 and some of you haven't
seen since 1990 91 when I was here on
sabbatical it's good to be back and and
whether one can get a whole life and a
whole book into an hour I greatly doubt
but I will try to give you some of it
and I know there are quite a few people
here who have read the book and I'm sure
they're quite a few others who haven't
so I'm sorry if I repeat something
you've already heard but I think you'll
hear something new as you just mentioned
Hutchinson himself what's called the
father of ecology in the Washington Post
in several other newspapers but he
always claimed said just disclaim that
he said the father of ecology was Darwin
and actually when I published the book I
got a letter a four page single spaced
letter back from birtley Egbert Lee
officially one of Hutchinson students
and part of the letter described how
Darwin had been the father of ecology
delving into various of Darwin's books
which was interesting but although he
did deny that he was the father of
ecology he did say that he did admit and
that he was he was the paternity agreed
that he was the paternity of many young
and promising ecologist so he was the
father of ecologist if not the father of
ecology stephen jay gould called
hutchinson the greatest living ecologist
when both of them were living and in EO
Wilson's preface to the book or forward
to the book he said I'm going to read
you a few quotes here but mostly I'm
just going to talk to you chivonne
Hutchinson was a pioneer of modern
ecology and justifiably called his
founder the one who brought the
discipline into the modern synthesis of
evolutionary theory he was a polymath a
master teacher and one of the few
scientists who could unabashedly be
called a genius a compared him to Max
Planck and to Einstein he lived in the
Golden Age of ecology and perhaps he
helped make the Golden Age of ecology
Hutchinson Wilson said was ideally
suited for his major role in his
forefront he was interested in almost
everything and that indeed is true
someone wrote that he was
interested in everything except pop
music and professional sports but he did
teach a jazz a rhythm course with a jazz
musician right here at Yale and Tom
Lovejoy has a good story about Hutchison
and pop music maybe he'll tell you later
so then the next OOP just right I I
never saw never saw evil and looking
like this because I I met him at the
time of the last photo in when he
retired in 1971 but Tom must have I
think Tom new Hutchinson longer and
better than probably anybody in the room
but I'm not sure about that tell us the
next oops sorry oh the first picture I
never mentioned that that little
creature there is a pot oh it's a
prosimian that one of the Yale graduate
students brought back from West Africa
and then the student left what didn't
bring this baby bought the parents and I
think unexpectedly it had a baby and one
of Hutchinson students were Dean
Anderson raised this baby and Hutchinson
brought him to one of his animal
behavior lectures and the last I think
the last of course of ecology that he
gave and supposedly the little Pato was
playing in his hair or what was left of
it anyhow uh and that indeed is
Hutchinson uh as a small child with his
mother his mother was a interesting
person interested in women's suffrage
making speeches about how life could be
better for women not a not a
professional social worker but she did a
lot of lecturing she wrote a book an
actual marriage manual called creative
sex she didn't sign her name to it just
her initials and she got a clergyman to
write the preface but she did try to
convince people that contraception was a
good thing it must have been quite
shocking to some of her Cambridge
friends I think and even wrote something
about her his mother and her
and I think this also shows evilyn as a
really good writer and giving you
pictures through his words one's
mother's friends seemed essentially
non-visual dressing in brown grey and
dark green cryptid colors cryptic colors
that faded into the landscape they
themselves were large boned and vigorous
with a strictly constitutional passion
for women's suffrage when they rode
through the town on their bicycles it
was difficult not to absorb the
impression that men were responsible for
all the evil in the world his father in
the next picture I get this right this
time OOP father on the right there oh I
got a laser picture here I think work no
that work well anyway the one on the
left there is his mother in an older age
and who's in the middle Gandhi by this
time his father who had only been a
lecturer when when Hutchinson was going
up in the family although pretty
upper-class was was not very rich but by
this time he was the master of a college
and had a natural professorship and
entertained visitors the woman on the
left is the one that took care of Gandhi
and he wrote about his father that he
and his father made many trips together
they walked around Cambridge in the
hills there and also in the hills of
Cumberland his father's knowledge said
evil and included wildflowers geology
meteorology and British archaeology
which the two of them explored together
and even wrote that later in life quote
when he explored new sites unaccompanied
by his father he always tried to think
about what he was looking out in his
father's terms he always cared about
what his father thought of him and
whether he was living up to his father's
hopes for him and even as an old man he
wrote a letter to his younger sister
Dorothea asking whether she thought that
father would have approved of all of his
work
they were quite close Oh see the next
one is here this is Hutchinson as a boy
scout during World War one he had
certain duties that he carried out I
think he's about 11 or 12 here but the
story I like best about his childhood
occurred when I went a concert sir
george darwin and his wife were dinner
guests and there were two sort sir
darwin sons of darwin's living in
Cambridge both of whom were friends of
the Hutchinson's but at that time
Hutchison must have been about nine and
his younger brother Leslie about seven
and he wrote that lady Darwin and a
magnificent cerise dress came to dinner
at the Hutchinson's along with George
two small boys watched from the top of
the stairs evilyn and Leslie crept down
the stairs quietly locked the
dining-room door turned off the electric
light at the main switch and threw the
key in the garden that's all we hear of
the story whether they turn the lights
on or not I don't know but at the very
end of his life when he received the
Kyoto award in Japan he told this story
and also said that he he hope he was
glad no anti evolutionary group had
honored him for his anti Darwinian act
another thing that happened at this age
during World War one a young woman that
they called gwendal was billeted with
them she was doing some work in
Cambridge and she became a lifelong
friend of the whole family and during
World War Two she had married a Jewish
man and during World War two they were
so afraid the Nazis were going to invade
London that the Hutchinson's offered to
have the little girl his name is jameel
to come and stay with them during the
war so at age two she went off in a boat
to New Haven their pictures of evil and
picking her up although it says it's a
boy and he and Margaret raised her until
she was five when she went what went
back home so actually Emil was and she
became a ballet dancer and then a ballet
instructor and she
living in London at present so I guess
she knew even longer than any of you
here okay well then he went off to
gresham school which was in Norfolk and
I think if his father are seeing his
interest in Natural History and Science
decided to send him to an English public
school that specialized in science or
beast was some courses in science not so
much ancient languages and actually he
took his Cambridge exam Cambridge
University exams in chemistry physics
and mathematics there were at that time
no biology exams I mean the word biology
was taught but no no such exams to get
into Cambridge and the amount of these
sciences that he learned as a high
school student stood him in good grace
the rest of his life I think he was
always better trained in these hard
sciences as we call them that most least
during my period most American ecologist
were were so trained and he was able to
use that in a lot of his work and he
also belonged to a natural history club
everywhere he seemed from the youngest
time there was always a natural history
club even in elementary school and he
belonged to almost all the seven
sections including being Secretary of
entomology and of geology in the 419
there's all the notebooks from this
natural history club or still exam 1920
the most North noteworthy achievements
of the Society for that year first was
Hutch's and discovery of a new a water
bug new to Britain and he was already
into water bugs and he also was the
first cope first prize winner for her
paper he wrote about variation in the
spittle bug but his comment on all of
this was that his school would have been
better to be good at cricket he wrote
about this though put him in the next
picture this is actually at Cambridge I
remember one good friday probably 1919
when the day was free after Chapel but
it was still in his Chapel closed using
such willpower to practice Tai
trations in the chemistry laboratory
over and over before I allowed myself a
visit to my favorite ponds and woods
feeling that I should have to be an
adequate chemist if I were to be become
a good field biologist for sea route
that wrote this many years later but
sounds good he did it this age well he
was at this age writing letters back and
forth and visiting entomologist and
becoming quite an expert at the the
group he had chosen which was the water
bugs he decided very early in elementary
school that butterflies were too
commonplace and they needed to do
something more esoteric and by the time
he got to Cambridge people were writing
to him for advice on identifying their
water bugs and related creatures there's
one and that family creek city is one of
the two families that he was
particularly interested in Pam where he
wasn't just interested in water bugs he
was also interested in stoats and there
was a lot that was written about Stokes
I discovered after a while that they're
just weasels and actually this one is
probably the same or very similar
species to ours but he was interested in
the variation in their coat color and
just before they took their final exams
at Cambridge he and grace Pickford who
became his first wife but who was his
field companion at Cambridge University
and two other people one was Robin Hill
the responsible for those discovery of
the light reactions and photosynthesis
and the other was another young woman Co
student who became aluminum knowledge
asst no here they are the one in the
left is the future alumni gist they
calls her klopse because she was so big
and the one down there the little one
that looks like a boy for which she was
sometimes mistaken at Yale is Grace
Pickford who became his wife this is a
look later picture ever so they went to
whole group of the Channel Islands
looking for stoats of different colors
and had lots of adventures and came back
and did very well on their exams that's
Penelope Jenkin is the limb knowledge
estándar viewed her at a very old age
and I
part of North Wales and she was still a
very feisty person who done a lot of
good limnology had been a professor at a
British university and actually
influenced evil and early on with his
limnology work after that he wanted it
when he graduated from Cambridge with
two upper first to first he won a
fellowship or Rockefeller fellowship to
study at the naples illogical station
and there's funny cop correspondence
there because he got a letter he wanted
to know what equipment they had or could
get for him and got a letter back
addressed to miss miss evil and
Hutchinson and they had to explain that
he was really male later he always told
people it was evil and as an evil one
whoa who was more famous but before he
didn't get much it didn't make much
progress with the endocrinology of the
octopus but he got very involved in love
of Italy and learned Italian later
lectured in Italian and went back to
Italy to do some work on lakes but
before his year was up he got a job
offer to be a senior lecturer in South
Africa it with water and university and
his parents that several other people
told him no no don't go there because
professor Phantom is a terribly
difficult person to get along with he
throwing the last lecturer forcibly out
of the laboratory but I think that
evilyn would spend most of his time in
Cambridge or near Cambridge really
wanted to explore a new world wanted to
snooze a zoologist he wanted to see some
new animals not so much lions and
elephants but particularly on a cough
aura which is a small phylum somewhere
between the annelids what in the
arthropods though I think molecular
biologists have now decided it's nearer
the arthropods which is husband it's a
gone a lot of species it actually
probably goes back to the or at least
its progenitors go back to the Burgess
Shale 550 million years ago but they
were several species in South Africa and
he did find them in he actually wrote a
little paper about them in 1927 so off
he went and just as predicted phantom
didn't get along with with him and and
actually fired him from teaching
after the first year but later there was
a trial and this was cleared up but
nevertheless they couldn't fire him all
together they still had to pay him
because he had a two year contract and
at that point on a professor at the
University of Cape Town and englishmen
land Lancelot Hagman who had already
done some very good scientific work in
England and was somehow connected either
with with Eva one's father who knew
everybody or with somebody that was at
gresham school offered to have him come
down and grace Pickford as well and do
some work on the dry lakes or Pam's in
his part of South Africa which they did
and that was the beginning of evil ins
work in limnology and that's when he
decided that was going to be his future
career and he had really very little
literature to go on at that point but
when he in between what before he left
cell after he left South Africa and
before he came to Yale he stopped in
Cambridge and found the work of the
Europeans Needleman and other of the
Europeans who really looked at the
chemistry and physics of lakes as well
as the creatures in them and adopted
that kind of approach and I think we can
know who the later picture done by
Marion cone of all the creatures that
were named after Hutchinson and most of
these creatures I think with the
exception of the turtle even he waitin
worked at fish for a while he had worked
on so this whole world of aquatic
creatures was part of the work that he
did with grace and with another young
woman from the University they didn't
publish these papers until they got to
Yale and then they published them
interesting enough in European journals
because I think you one felt that was
the where the real phenology was
happening he has sometimes been called
the father of limnology or the father of
American limnology G but there were
other American women John technologists
before him and surely the Europeans were
doing good work so maybe we can call him
the father of the new limnology
incorporating statistics and mathematics
which hadn't happened before well after
his time was up he was worried about
what he was going to do now
and someone has just written a long
article about Hutchinson's two years in
south africa south african woman
professor who sent me the article and
she found something that I didn't find
and that was letters of evil and that he
wrote to his father a whole bunch of
letters I actually looked in the
archives today and I found more I don't
know they might have been given to Yale
later after i had had looked for them
but it's very interesting one of the
letters he's telling his father what he
would like to do he would like to spend
six years more all together in South
Africa but that didn't prove possible
but he was applying for jobs as one job
as a demonstrator and I like a lab
instructor at Cambridge University
under-gardener one of his professors and
he even applied for a job being a
teacher in an elementary school which
tried to teach children four and a half
to ten the scientific method well
fortunately he didn't have to do either
of those things because lasted hogben
found out about a fellowship at yale on
which he could could perhaps take to
study embryology with the famous ross
harrison who had lost harrison had
invented tissue culture sometime around
1910 had become quite famous for that
because she could look at live nerve
cells in vitro which is something that
hadn't been done before but he had been
for several years now the head of the
department at yale and also had quite an
extensive research group working on
particularly spotted salamanders but
other amphibians and trans doing
experimental embryology transplanting
limbs from one place to another so it
was pretty late but even when applied
for this fellowship he sent everything i
answered all the questions on a telegram
and sent them in but it was too late all
the Fellowship's have been given out but
it turned out that a termite man had
just left Yale to go to Berkeley and
there was an instructor ship open and
sight unseen they asked him if he would
like it so first he inquired as to
whether grace could have a place in the
laboratory but sure that that was true
he he wrote one word in the telegram
except and and two of them both of them
went off to Yale in nineteen twenty
before he left also he found the book
again back in Cambridge that Elton
Charles Elson had written out animal
ecology and even said that if there had
been someone between Darwin you know
another progenitor it was Elton who
wrote all about food chains Hutchinson's
himself carried it much further but
there has been some discussion about how
much influence there was between the two
they were not close friends but but
someone pointed out they live the same
over the same lifespan Hutchinson was
born in nineteen three and Elton 1900
and they both died in the same year but
it seems to me that those three years
made a difference because the book came
out altas book came out in 1927 in 1927
was when evil and was looking for a job
and had really not accomplished very
much however is a tues interesting
stories about elton one of them is in
the book and it was a story from Max
Dunbar who's in in my book those of you
who read it in the first crop of
students although he was not actually a
Hutchinson graduate student he was an
Oxford advanced Oxford undergraduate
hadn't who had a research year in at
Yale and decided to work with Hutchinson
and they correspond it after that for a
long time Dunbar became a professor at
McGill and did a lot of interesting work
on Arctic limnology but he had been
Dunbar had been an Oxford walking down
the broad or the broad street one day
and he saw what he said that the two
progenitors of most of modern ecology
Hutchinson in Elton walking down the
street engaged in deep conversations and
he said wouldn't it be good if we know
what they were talking about of course
we can but I met Elton too I would I did
a degree of to say something about
myself here a undergraduate degree at
Cornell starting in ornithology and also
in zoology and a master's degree in
plant taxonomy and genetics i got
married in between to this fellow over
here so i had to stay of cornell and
dove and then after
without after subsequently I did a PhD
in experimental ecology not experimental
in using evolutionary ecology and that's
when I read all Hutchinson books and
papers and became a Hutchins Sounion
even dedicated my thesis to him but I
didn't meet him during that period of
time but in between those two things
Glen over here what a Guggenheim which
enabled him to spend a year studying
physics in Oxford and I came along with
our three children quite small and very
fortunately got a job as a demonstrator
which is just a sort of glorified lab
instructor in the botany school but the
first semester botanist and soul so all
just took a course together and taxonomy
and evolution something I knew about and
so I got to teach them that and I was
much more excited about it than the
Oxford students you know they did the
lab but there were no lack exam so they
didn't really hang around a long time
but all the people whose books i had
read I'd taught a little ecology course
than the meantime David Lough who was a
close friend of Hutchinson's a B Ford
Darlington the cattle well all these
people were teaching freshman and most
of them were in the lab lacked with his
ring gulls and the melodic laws and all
these things so I was very excited about
that and then this third semester term
that year I was the lab instructor
teaching assistant for ecology and we
did a lot of field trips in around
Oxford some to famous places like
whiting woods but one day an elderly
Matt or so it seemed to me at that time
came with us that that the professor
artists working with Stanley Bedell had
invited and the students didn't pay much
attention but Stan introduced me to him
and it was Charles Alton and you know I
knew he I dread the book he wrote it in
1927 I didn't even think he was still
alive but but we had a wonderful
discussion about I was working on salt
marshes at that time on the on the North
Sea so that was a very good experience
for me so I'm sure they had a good
discussion on the broad but I don't know
what it was all right
um back to this minute Harrison was very
good to Hutchinson and Hutchinson gave
him a lot of credit his field was
completely different from Hutchinson's
uh and he didn't ever work in embryology
immediately got put into undergraduate
teaching and it was too busy to either
get a graduate degree which was his wife
Grace Pickford got a PhD at that point
but he did have to teach embryology
which he wasn't probably an expert out
but a Harrison allowed him to do a whole
lot of different things that which you
wouldn't think would be a good route to
being a dinner assistant professor so he
published papers and all kinds of things
even psychoanalysis in those first years
but also Harrison nominated him to be
the chief biologist for uh Norton Lee
the Yale North India expedition and he
wrote a whole Hutchinson wrote a whole
plan and it went through the president
and they went off for almost a year and
when over mountain ranges and up to
lakes that were at 18,000 feet and
Hutchinson had to collect everything he
actually did some taxidermy that was six
kill he'd learned in England that nobody
else knew about but mostly he studied
the high elevation lakes and and also
the people who lived there and this is
North India but is now Ladakh and build
Ozaki people where the women were
clothed in these beautiful dresses with
lots of turquoises and in some of these
lakes it was so cold that the ice hardly
melted and it was not possible to fish
for fish to live there so sometimes the
top predator would be a kadhai Suren he
wrote a book about this experience
called the clear mirror which was a
literary success although I don't think
it's so very copies until it was
reprinted by some people locally here he
wrote it in 1937 and it was repeated be
reprinted in 1973 the pattern of life
and Goa and Indian Tibet and the word
pictures in this book and I think some
of it might be in Dave scallion halls
book
I just got to read you one little
paragraph about lakes in the desert they
vary in color with in a restricted range
of blues and greens just like the
turquoise is that they resemble which
ladakh you women wear each shade of blue
or green sums up in itself a structure
and history in the lake that is for each
lake is a small world making the make
its nature known to the larger world of
the desert by its colors in this
particular Lake almost 18,000 feet the
last snow of June melts but there are no
fish too extreme conditions for fish but
three crustaceans tiny submicroscopic
one black one red and one pale grey in
the blue water black spots move
leisurely here and there and still tiny
or bright red points because these are
you know almost there microscopic or
submicroscopic you can actually see
something's their little ones the red
ones can be seen as skipping about among
them and in the deeper water small pale
grey shrimps scurry about you could all
picture that and here is the North India
expedition they camped they had very
primitive conditions sometimes rode
elephants they're all dressed up and
what are supposed to be ladakhi or
Tibetan I don't even know which one is
evil and in this picture figure it out
and he made his later in life later at
Yale people made fun of his clumsy way
with glassware I mean apparently glass
tubes were falling out of his pockets
with holes in them on crashing on the
ground but during this expedition not in
the equipment he'd sent over seem to
have gotten there and he had to scrounge
pieces of old equipment and make himself
he did quite a lot of experimental work
and seem to have done that very well and
I maybe later in life you really prefer
to be a theorist but at this point he
was doing a lot of experimental ecology
and he wrote letters to grace Pickford
throughout this expedition explaining
his experiments sometimes even with
graphs even though they were about to
get divorced that had been decided early
and that did happen and the folklore is
and I've never been able to see to tell
whether this story is actually true he
met his next wave also in English woman
Margaret on the boat coming back from
from well had to go to Europe first from
India to the United States and she was a
singer and was singing on the boat and
they fell in love Wow so they were
married for 50 years though sadly the
last 10 years of that she had
Alzheimer's and and Hutchinson took care
of her at home with some help from
various graduate students and other
people for the last 10 years of her life
she was not interested in science
graduate students told me that had known
her that they were invited to the
Hutchinson's for sherry and a concert
that you that Margaret would give I see
people nodding here and if she would ask
a graduate student what he was working
on and after the first two sentences her
eyes would glaze over and she would go
and get some more sherry or whatever but
but they did have in common art and
music and literature and when she was
away for some time in Italy he wrote her
the most wonderful letters about the art
exhibits and the concerts he went to he
was an inveterate letter writer
wonderful for a biographer because there
are hundreds and hundreds of letters he
wrote to his graduate students they
wrote back to him for years and years I
he wrote letters to both of his wives
here and later on I think there's a
picture coming he wrote literally
hundreds of letters to the famous writer
Rebecca West who had seen one of his
articles in the American scientists he
wrote a whole series of articles in the
American scientists for years and years
that all aspects of science and she she
wrote to him and said she wanted to meet
him she was already a quite famous
novelist and after whole series of funny
telegrams she finally did meet him and
that was in the 40s and they remained
friends until she died in in 1983 she
also wrote for The New Yorker a reporter
as well as a novelist for The New Yorker
and the
herald-tribune and she would come over
to New York quite often so they could
get together oh here we finally come to
the most important thing um these this
is a family tree that um Marion coned
the wife of Alan Cohen one who catches
his students made in 1971 for his
retirement booklet of L&O limnology and
oceanography and it's not complete of
course and when it goes up to nineteen
seventy one and there's at least two
more generations after that in a sense i
consider myself ochen Sounion but only
by his writings but that would have been
the next generation and many of these
people as you can see had a whole lot of
graduate students in a lot of different
fields mythology to anibal behavior
oceanography all kinds of different
things Larry slabodka I don't know if I
can make this work but he's up on the
right there I had many graduate students
at Stony Brook and I went to his I got
to know him quite well because he wrote
an article together for the English
journal endeavor and I was his graduate
students all gave talks his former
graduate students at his retirement
party in a whole lot of different fields
quite like Mike hutchinson oh so I think
he was the progenitor of many important
you know ecologists the first one who
was Gordon Riley and I've got time
you'll have to look in the book for a
whole lot about golden Gordon Riley he
started working with in biogeochemistry
because that what that's exactly what
Hutchinson was famous for in the earlier
days of his career and eventually became
a marine biologist and had his own group
in dalhousie and then there was a DV who
may have been the only one in that in
that period who managed to step step
over the barrier between the botany
department and the zoology department
both in the same building but is if
there was a wall in between and people
usually didn't go from one to the other
but a DV had done a masters in the
botany department and then he wanted to
work on Lake cores and apparently nobody
in the
department was very interested in that
but evilyn was and so he came over and
work with hutchinson and he did a
remarkable PhD theses probably the first
one at least in this country on paleo
limnology but he also studied all the
living creatures as well in a whole both
the liz leap on which was Hutch's his
favorite place near here but in a whole
lot of other lakes and then there was
Tommy Edmondson on the left there WT
Edmondson famous for his later reversal
with his graduate students a Lucian of
Lake Washington in Seattle and I think
that was the first time that had been
shown to be possible on a major scale
but he came into evil ones lab as a high
school student because she had somebody
had his brother I think had given him a
microscope when he was about 12 and he
discovered rotifers in the pond water
and the family moved to New Haven never
a good high school teacher who took him
over to Yale and introduced him to
several people in the department and
Hutchinson had him move into his lab and
when when Hutchinson went to North India
he collected among other things rotifers
which he thought he could work on and he
sighed decided that actually Tommy who
is I think at that point I think by then
he was an undergraduate student at Yale
um worked on him on almost all of them
are most of them and was very surprised
when the paper came out and it it was
Edmondson and Hutchinson is he didn't
think a professor would do that and
actually even rarely put his names on
his graduate student his name on his
graduate students papers Tommy did a PhD
on on the road of furs and invented
several new things and he also was a
great help to me with this book because
he had all kinds of sources that he kept
sending me and was very encouraging and
here are some creatures Glenn said I
should put some creatures in for people
who are not familiar with water bugs
that cut Justin worked on so now we have
quickly a whole bunch of creatures but
Hutchinson and later his students worked
on and the point is here that there's a
great variety of them so
I'm just gonna go through these these
are that's a water bug also copepods
paper the bout copepods he even looked
at beetles another of his friends did
beetles when he was little little and I
put that in blue footed boobie he did
not work on them but he did write a
great big compendium book on guano
fascinating book that I thought I might
have been the only one who read the
whole 500 pages but at a recent meeting
I met a young man who was after doing a
thesis about guano no he had read the
whole book as well that's very
interesting ollie but the guano book
also talks about El Nino I think the
first time that anybody got together a
whole lot of different factors which he
measured which seemed to be related to
El Nino it's quite Darwinian book
because he wrote letters to all kinds of
people ship captains people who ran
fertilizer businesses all kinds of
islands in the Pacific and put all that
data together even even guano from
ancient extinct organisms Hutchinson
also worked on plants so that's not so
widely known and he wrote a whole volume
of the treatise for volume treatise on
lon ology on aquatic plants and he
actually worked on land plants that's
something he probably another wise
didn't do but this was part of
biogeochemistry to we was interested in
like a podiums they're all different
Jenner and out but they accumulate
aluminum and he was correlating he got
his graduate students to send them
different species from the United States
in England correlating the morphology
and the aluminum content and that became
part of one of the volumes of the
biogeochemistry old treatise that he did
for the American Museum of Natural
History there's some rotifers one down
bottom seems we've got lost and daphnia
several of his feet his Johnny Brooks
and other people worked on daphnia gadaa
Suren Alan Cohen worked on cone shells
spelled differently marine cone shells
and Hutchinson thought that each of his
student
they shouldn't be tax on of us but they
should really know well some group of
organisms that they were working on and
several of his art students worked in
marine ecosystems Tom Howard HT Odom
sometimes called Tom and sometimes
Howard did a lot of ecosystem work and
marine systems but one of the first was
was Tom Goro who I think was the only
Hutchinson student that got both a PhD
and a medical medical degree and he when
he finished it both of them was offered
a job in Jamaica actually at the Medical
School but what he really wanted to do
was work on the coral reefs and someone
had told him that there was a Marine
stationed in Jamaica he got down there
and discovered that was not true at all
but he started one discovery day and
later on in my career I was teaching
marine biology and Jamaica during
January terms and I actually went over I
was at a different station went to
discovery babe see when I could find out
about Tom Goro because he died quite
young but he and his wife Nora who is
also a marine biologist actually worked
out a lot of the relationship between
the alga the zooxanthellae and the the
letter at the animal Carl animal and
wrote about it and I used those papers
with my students but did anyway Tom grow
was an important marine biologist and
his son also Tom growers is a Carl
expert more Carl and Tom Lovejoy worked
on birds in Brazil and MacArthur worked
on wood warblers barilla d this is a
black voted green Warbler many of us
study brought orbiters and Hutchinson
always said MacArthur knew his birds and
MacArthur did work on other birds later
but I belonged to a field zoology club
at Cornell Jordan I and all of us knew
our warmers so we didn't think that was
so difficult I thought thought so a
plankton when I took a plankton courses
a graduate student much more difficult
than workers that one's actually up in
the spruce trees see by the Lycans
and actually Maxine Watson what if his
students worked on on mosses and my
students don't always believe that Moses
have sex but they do the sperm from the
male has to go through water and arrive
at the female to of tree ferns too and
this Maxine wanted to do some but she
was doing population biology too and you
can actually age each shoot of this
particular kind of loss but you wanted
to do some experiments on competition
between the first phase called Pro
Dyneema so she sent max teen to me after
I had had met him in 1971 to see if I
could help her well I'm not very good at
this kind of culture but in my
department there was a student of
MacArthur who had done his his PhD on
cellular slime mold so he was able to
help xine and then the results and jolly
who became an expert on lemurs
especially the ring-tailed lemur and
finally we have an anthropology student
merdeen answers and who claimed
hutchinson as well she worked on the
people that lived in Lapland and herded
reindeer and she and Hutchinson got into
all kinds of discussions about the
behavior of reindeer so a whole lot of
different feels that they work in and
there's some reason I'm telling you this
because oh how do we get that one oh
sorry oh there's been a lot of writing
in history science on research schools a
research school started in Europe
particularly in Germany touches his
father worked with Emile Fisher got a
medical degree actually in Germany
Harrison had done that to the classic
research schools I wrote some things
down here there was usually one subject
some set of questions they were trying
to answer some set of tools and there
was usually a hair professor Harrison
himself was called the chief and I think
the students are quite fond of him it
wasn't quite like the sum of the
dictatorial professors in Europe but it
was definitely a research school and I
wrote something about Hutchinson's
research school in an early paper and I
was I was criticized by another
historian of science saying that wasn't
a research school that was a research
group
and you might be right because
hutchinson students were not like that
they worked in not only on all these
different organisms but in all these
different fields and Hutchinson worked
in most of these fields himself not in
marine biology or biological
oceanography and not specifically an
animal behavior but most of the others
there as well as in some other fields I
just put the science ones in because
there wasn't room but he also worked on
the history of animal art from
illuminated manuscripts he also wrote
papers in history of science and have
students in history of science so he was
a polymath and there's a whole chapter
in the book about that one thing the
review if you some of you saw the review
in science the one thing the reviewer
did note was that I talked about
Hutchinson encouraging women in out Roy
Hutchinson respected women scientists
and I think that started at Cambridge
because at that time women could not get
Cambridge degrees not too much much
later his sister younger sister Dorothea
I went to Cambridge and completed her
work and she didn't she was able to go
to a graduation ceremony in her late 80s
to get her her actual degree and another
one of her friends whom I also did
interview who was in Hutchinson's class
was in her 90s by then but they were
able in touch insist I'm to work in the
lab with a men and so we got to know
these women quite well and among them
there were five women including grace
accrued and doing the others who became
well-known scientists in there in quite
a variety of fields one of them in
astronomy who ended up at Harvard pain
slovakian so he did both respect but
also help and empower women even after
they left yell he kept track of them and
wrote to them and helped them to find
positions and here just a couple of them
allison jolly who actually did her work
largely in our behavior and donna
haraway who's now quite a
uh well known feminist theorist and she
did her work in history of science with
hutchinson any dean he encouraged other
women who were not as students up there
is janet brown who is now a professor at
harvard he helped her with her first
book which was about biogeography one of
the things Hutchinson was always
interested in and the other one is here
in kingsland who was a professor at
Johns Hopkins and he wrote a very good
book about population biology and their
letters and letters between them while
she was writing this book and surely
gave her a good start and the one down
below some of you may know Kathryn
Skinner she taught a course with
Hutchinson I think she was on his only
woman colleague in biogeochemistry in
the in the late 60s with also with
someone named Jim Walker as a graduate
course and she is still teaching in the
geology department she also worked in
the medical school on the on
crystallography and bone so he's had a
lot of women colleagues and friends and
there are many many letters some of them
gave me whole series of letters most of
which i didn't use in the book he also
was a close friend of Margaret Meads
helped her write her one of her later
books she stayed at his house and Yale
when when she came to talk here and he
stayed in her house and and her her
husband Gregory Bateson Gregory Bateson
had been an elementary school student
with with Hutchinson in England so he
kept up with him all his life and during
the period when the two of them were
together there were the macy conferences
in cyber cybernetics and and feedback
conferences and they invited Hutchinson
to come to those conferences and he said
he wrote that he was just a listener but
actually he wrote a paper and gave a
talk and it was printed as a paper they
sort of combined ecology and cybernetics
on cycles which became quite well-known
and here he is at this period
he still looks quite English he never
lost his English accent and one of them
one of my friends who studied American
who married in Englishman who came here
and did an environmental science degree
early or whatever it was called then
said she never could understand his
lectures is a accent was so thick here I
have to we can't say only good things
about Hutchinson a friend interviewed
someone named edna poro who was actually
a gordon riley student
but the four corner alley went to
Dalhousie and must have been because he
took Hutchinson courses and he said that
MacArthur came to his office to play
darts that was something I didn't find
out but he said that that Hutchinson a
bad habit of standing right in front of
what he wrote on the blackboard and
after he had done a very nice drawing
probably kadarin Nikora waited patiently
for hutchinson moved to the side so that
he could copy it however he didn't and
he looked down and saw that Ted had not
copied it and told him he needed to pay
better attention to the lecture so so he
had his foibles as well but he was still
dressed in tweeds when I came to talk
with him in in 1990 but not probably as
naughty is this okay so if he were was
the father of modern ecology or at least
so in my view he was together with many
of his graduate students all these
different fields came into being during
his time radio ecology ecosystem ecology
it should be American biogeochemistry
because that was well established in
Europe before Hutchinson a population
ecology and theoretical ecology and
that's saying he was the only one that
did these things but he certainly was
the one who who incorporated all these
fields into ecology and here we start
with the Radio isotopes he was the first
one to use Radio isotopes his tracers
and actually that work I looked back and
discovered that he had actually started
that work in 1941 during the war when he
managed to get a little bit of p32 and
took it out in a leaky boat and at that
time it was Tommy Edmondson in the boat
so he told me about it and they didn't
actually get enough of it to really get
any good data but it was something that
he had mind quite a while before he
actually did it with von bohlen that was
the first paper they published in I do
47 and they essentially sprinkled be 32
in the lake and saw where it went and
what how it cycled it was the first time
that had been done
actually some some people at Dalhousie
we're doing rather similar experiments
but they didn't know why they were doing
them I mean they had better equipment is
that they knew what they were doing but
they didn't out they didn't understand
they didn't have that hypothesis that
Hutchinson had they were just seeing
what happened to the phosphorus but von
bone and Hutchinson published there's
first and the Dalhousie group had
written to Hutchinson to discuss these
experiments before they publish them in
the second paper there two papers the
second one is a lot better science to
the first one but this is the one that's
always quoted and then then came Raymond
lindemann who had already done his PhD
he was I think the first post doc and
there on that diagram family tree that
you saw all those little creatures
flying around and walking around are the
postdocs if you look on each each have a
name hit quite a lot of postdoctoral
students and they essentially together a
wrote a paper called the trophic dynamic
aspect of ecology and that paper it was
lindemans of data but Hutchison really
added a lot to the paper and that that
has been documented earlier by Bob cook
and also to some extent by Joel pagan
and myself but the paper was turned down
because they scenery the knowledge astir
be viewed it said it was too early for
anything theoretical in ecology in
limnology and that Lindemann should go
to 100 more lakes before he came to any
general conclusions but Hutchinson wrote
to the editor of ecology who was the
young Tom parks at that point explaining
why this paper was important that they
should publish it and park stuck his
neck out and did publish it sadly
lindemann died he had some kidney
problem before the paper was published
but it was the first paper in eco system
or systems ecology and you can see him
in the lab there with his glass were
during this period so I think he did go
on doing experiments for some of this
time and then we get to biogeochemistry
in the US this is the picture of the two
your two of the European founders of the
field and what Hutchinson did was to
discover the work of Vernadsky
and hutchins I don't think he will he
read Russian but he did read almost
every other language and it had been
translated into French but had not been
Verne asked his work had not been
translated into English and he had that
done at Yale so that his students could
read these papers and that became his
major project the American Museum of
Natural History actually gave him a
large grant to he didn't do all the work
himself to collect biogeochemistry many
many different kinds and quite a few of
his students worked on biogeochemistry
in fact by 1948 he was so well known as
a bow geochemist more so than an
ecologist the US Geological Survey tried
very hard to hire him and they offered
him this plum job he could work on
anything he liked they would get him all
the equipment he needed he didn't have
to write grant proposals they would do
all of his paperwork and pushes they
wrote back that he'd been offered
several jobs and this one was the most
tempting but that he wouldn't be able to
have graduate students if he did that
and it already produced for young been
at the beginning they were all men who
were well on their way to becoming
important ecologists themselves and he
didn't want to give that up so I think
the paternity of ecologist was extremely
important part of Hutchinson's career
and he he had a particular method of
teaching graduate students which I think
started in his own experiences is what
he called a hunter and gatherer at
Cambridge University and cambridge
university as a character in the book
there was a lot about that it was
probably many people thought it was the
center of intellectual life in the whole
world in the interwar period certainly
was that that was true in in science but
other fields as well they need sort of
decided that that American students were
much too they have too many exams there
was they were sent down a path and they
had to do this lab experiment that lab
experiment and that was not even a good
way to teach undergraduates graduate
students but but he also inherited some
of this from his professors and ye'll
though we are here okay then we get to
do
population ecology and there were quite
a few students and Hutchison himself or
worked in population ecology you can
tell the era there was Larson thought
can without a beard and also with a was
that who knows what that is a slide rule
right he worked on a lot of different
things but for his first work was on red
tides dinoflagellates and Robert
MacArthur who did this famous work with
all the Warblers we were all jealous
because we know all those warbirds but
we never thought of doing such a study
with them and of course we only saw them
on that Gration when they went through
if the co or east rock over here oh but
he saw them when there were they were
breeding and figured out how they
divided up the niche space on a spruce
tree very good neighbor and we get to
the niche theory for which budget is
probably most famous and there's been a
lot of discussion about in the
literature I'll starting back in the 70s
including a paper that was called Santa
Rosalia we'll get to that that was one
of Hutch's his most famous writings
Santa Rosalia was a goat apparently in
the church of santa rosalia there were
goat remains but there were there were a
lot of people saying detrimental things
about mostly MacArthur and Hutchison
that competition had been too much
emphasized and some of the things some
of the ratios that Hutchinson had put
out didn't turn out to be true perfectly
true but whenever you put out a number
like 1 point 3 2 1 somebody will do lots
of experiments and find a different
number or find that yours isn't hold up
but many people and MacArthur to had a
lot of hypotheses that other people
tested and a lot of good work was done
but I do think that finish theory I
wrote this in my last chapter called
concluding remarks
has turned out to be extremely useful I
used it a lot in my own work and
Hutchinson a Robert Cole well and they
are go wrangle both know i think at
University of Connecticut wrote an
interesting paper which was too late for
my book but they wrote it was about not
only ecology but biogeography
Hutchinson's realized niche has come to
express not only the effects of species
interactions as Hutchinson intended but
also constraints of dispersal limitation
and the lack of contemporary
environments corresponding to the
fundamental niche it has been used to
classify in map environments model
potential species distributions under
past present and future species and
simulate stochastic models and encompass
speciation extinction and evolutionary
adaptation to changing environments
quite a few things that can be used for
and I should just know without going
through this diagram I used a much
simpler one with squirrels in the book
about he's talked on the left or the
environmental characteristics including
a thermocline you can see in the middle
there and those small circles are small
phytoplankton and large circles are
large phytoplankton and s1 and s2 or two
different consumers that there was also
there also was unutilized or unavailable
its space and neither one of them
another fit into these two authors
claimed and I think they're probably
right that between the time he wrote the
original paper in 1957 and the time he
wrote his textbook in 1968 he actually
made changes and improvement and larger
accomplishing of his niche theory which
have been quite useful all right people
uh back in in 1957 when MacArthur was
still a graduate student a professor at
Duke had his student graduate students
an interview or write to students of
Hutchinson and ask them what their
experience was with Hutchinson is a
professor and it was very interesting
because
this was done at the same you know while
they were still students not ten or
twenty years later and MacArthur wrote
this first of all he regard the rope
that Hutchins had used methods of
radioactive tracers in a novel way
combined with the knowledge of
theoretical hydrodynamics to explain
motion of phosphorus in a pond he was
saying that several different examples
of how Hutchinson used what he'd learned
in the physical science in his studies
of ecology and then he says I believe a
few words about him as a teacher are in
order he never made appointments
students go into his room to discuss not
to get advice and are treated as equals
no matter how far-fetched their ideas I
believe he's influenced me the most by
his genuine enthusiasm about the small
novel ideas we may have this enthusiasm
is the most sincere sort of
encouragement I feel rather foolish
having said all this in print in a
letter but I hope it may contribute to
the understanding of a remarkable
markedly fine man between 1950 in 1958
there were 13 different PhD students of
Hutchinson's and eight of them became
major ecologists say in terms of
theoretical ecology these are our three
of his famous papers beyond the
concluding remarks which was at the end
of a conference a very diverse
conference and Hutchinson didn't have
good things to say about some of it but
that's what he introduced his in
dimensional ditch concept and another
most famous one homage to Center Roselia
why are there so many different kinds of
animals which has been much quoted in
one sense there were so many different
kind of animals because there were so
many different kinds of plants or other
kinds of food the animals were eating
but another one that I liked is the
paradox of the plankton these plankton
seemed to be living in quite uniform
environments and yet they all seem to be
managing to to coexist and of course the
competitive exclusion theory was rampant
at that time and he figured out a lot of
ways that they managed to do that
temporal ways water temperature
quite a few different things and I like
this one too but apology for the
ornithologist and since I started at an
art ethology stand never got to cook
plots for quite a long time you just
wanted to explain so about ideas to
people who were not studying limnology
but all of these articles on start with
if not water bugs at least freshwater
ecology organisms the lake organisms and
he actually developed I believe many of
his ideas starting with neurology
starting with the water bugs that he'd
been studying since she was 15 year olds
first paper at age 15 and going out from
there into these many different fields
he also had friends that had had nothing
to do with ecology in particular that's
Rebecca West a remarkable person at 18
she was an actress in London Rebecca
West is a pseudonym she was in a an
instant play where the main character
was named Rebecca West and after that
she about 19 she got a job as a literary
critic on it in London newspaper she
became hg wells mistress she started
writing novels herself and had this long
career she was actually on the cover of
Time magazine is the most famous women
writer but later in life she did a lot
of reporting nuremberg trials lynch
trials in the united states south africa
a lot of important things for the
newspaper and for the new yorker and the
two of them wrote letters almost daily
about their lives so you can read these
letters and find out what Hutchins was
doing what he was thinking and in the
next one here who oh there she is as the
author his letter are seeking the
letters that she sent him he gave to the
vine aki i don't think he charged them
he just gave him two by Nikki but she
died before the letters that Hutchinson
wrote to her were distributed and his
children her
her son sold them to the highest bidder
which was the University of Tulsa so I
spent several days reading these letters
at the University of Tulsa but the
letters were important in many finding
out many things and one of them had to
do with algebra a lot of people that
read this book including some of his
graduate students had no idea about
hutchinson's worked as an
environmentalist and you know I don't
think Hutchinson would have called
himself a feminist in that era he was
just a humanist who helped women and
environmentalists was a bad word to
mainstream ecologists during this period
and for quite a long time but he did
environmental work some of it was basic
research for which he won several
different environmental Awards and one
of them had to do with a green slime up
there eutrophication of lakes not the
natural eutrophication which simply
means enrichment of nutrients but
eutrophication was going on because of
human activities and he figured out that
phosphorus was the culprit all of us
soap sud companies didn't didn't believe
that or didn't want to believe that it
was later proved by other ecologists and
but he also worked in he's also always
someone who cared about biodiversity and
was really worried about extinction and
in his other career as a historian of
medieval art from these illuminated
manuscripts he actually looked at
biodiversity in birds in the 14th
century figured out what all those birds
were that were living in England during
that period from the illuminated
manuscripts the aldabra story is a
really interesting one and we really
wouldn't know what except for the
letters that he wrote to Rebecca West I
mean we it was known that he was he was
an early member of the National Academy
of Sciences and the National Academy
sent him to England to talk to the Royal
Society of which he was a foreign member
because the English and American
governments were trying to set up an
airfield on the island the valve
in the Indian Ocean and the members of
the world society were not being very
vocal about doing anything about it but
he described this whole trip in a letter
to Rebecca West and is very interesting
and I'll read you something here about
Al Dabra this is a letter of protest
about quote the imminent extinction of
the gigantic lab land tortoises the
giant tortoise flourished with a dodo
and the solitaire and while it is a
matter of lasting regret that not even a
few individuals of these curious birds
she'd have had the chance of surviving
the lawless conditions of past centuries
is confidently hope that the present
government and people will find a means
of saving the last examples of their
contemporaries and at that time there
was a lot of wood cutting but also that
was from 1874 and the signatories to
that letter included Charles Darwin and
actually they did stop the lumbering the
the work that they were doing to make it
an airbase would have really destroyed
not only the tortoise populations but a
lot of bird populations that were
endemic to the islands and finally
finally that didn't happen partly
because of a film that a British man
made of the island but partly I think
before sit also because of hutchins says
efforts and there's a line from McNamara
he said I'm sure glad to have although
scientists off my back when it finally
was resolved no whole career that was
something I made for different meeting
you also want to great many other honors
he won the franco franklin medal you
know which started with Benjamin
Franklin and Thomas Edison Edison is
winners and when he was asked what he
and what he had invented other people
said he had invented modern ecology and
this is being given out the person
speaking is with Patrick who was a long
time associated Hutchinson's from her
earliest days she worked on diatoms and
it's a fascinating diet I'm ecology that
I read early age and they work together
and lindsley pond early on and we
mein friends throughout their lives and
one on the right is a Mart Marjorie
Garber who is now a shake scary caught
scholar and professor at Harvard I think
their connection at Yale was at the
lisabetha club Johnson gave the whole
set of his reprints I sure wish I had
had one to two women who were not
biologists one to Marjorie Garver and 12
Phoebe Ellsworth another friend from his
college saybrook it and it Yale so he
did have close friends who were not
actually connected with his science he
was interested in all kinds of other
people's ideas finally Hutchison never
got a doctorate I discussed that in the
book and you could read it and see what
you think for one thing he didn't want
to stay in Cambridge after he graduated
one of his friends had written to
Cambridge you could actually send your
papers into cambridge and and obtain a
doctorate that way and I know someone
who did that but his friend was turned
down so I think early in his career who
was worried about that later in his
career he was famous and he was sort of
proud of not having a doctorate there's
a story about someone who was it Tom
came in addressed you both as dr.
Hutchison and dr. Lovejoy and and evil
and said oh I'm too old and Thomas too
young but he finally was given an honor
or degree together with Max roots and
the Archbishop of Canterbury and the
foreign minister and a woman professor
literature professor from Oxford that's
a whole bunch of them a tremendously
pompous thing and there he is with his
sister-in-law Hannah his brother
Leslie's wife afterwards and he was
already I think about 80 when this
happened on Margaret already was too ill
to go with him but his sister Dorothea
who became his correspondent after both
Margaret and Rebecca West died took care
of him and here he is in his old age
still at Yale he said it yell he did
work in writing all the time all the
time he was there and Christina spiezio
who I think is coming tonight did a
portrait him at this age and a bust
however he was worried that he was not
to finish the fourth volume of the
treatise inland ology while while he is
still alive and actually he got most of
the writing done but not the foot not
the figures and many loving people
finished the book for him students and
others and finally the age i think 83 he
won the kyoto prize he was the first
first scientist to win the Kyoto process
which is essentially the Japanese
equivalent of the Nobel Prize but
there's no Nobel Prize for ecologists
and at that point he was he was quite
frail but his third wife and took him
much younger than he took him to Tokyo
and back and he gave a really
interesting speech with some of his
ideas for instance about the evolution
of homosexuality a subject he was been
interested in off and on at that age and
finally his wife died unexpectedly and
his relatives took him back to England
and even after that he got to know some
of his nieces and nephews very well in
the short time he had to live and he
stayed with you nail the little girl who
had had lived with them during world war
two and had become a ballet dancer and I
think we're all here to celebrate his
life and I was oh I got one more thing I
gotta tell you Tom Odom one more quote
here he was the graduate student who
became a well-known systems ecologist
and he was actually on the list of
people to be invited to this lecture but
he died in nineteen you know in 2002 so
that was not possible I actually went
down to interview him in Florida while
he was still alive and I arranged this
with Odom beforehand and I got there and
I called up and his wife said no I
couldn't see him because he just come
home from the hospital after a brain
operation so I was very sorry about all
of that but I had friends there and I
stayed a couple more days and then he
called me and he said Nancy I'm much
better come on over and talk to me and
and we had a very interesting discussion
by that time he had become a
non-mainstream ecologist
but he still had a lot of people
especially in Europe that were
interested in his ideas on the queue he
had written two chapters and his brother
gene Odom's book which were probably the
most significant new chapters for
ecology and he also was one of those who
wrote about Hutchinson and this is the
last quote it is difficult for one
person to see the whole of a many
dimensional phenomenon in overriding
characteristic of Hutchinson is his
imaginative ability to use important
implications in small detailed matters
to see important implication is small
detailed matters and thus become
genuinely excited this absolute love of
knowledge is ideal as an environment for
the student who is getting his first
results or for an american-type student
raised in a materialistic society where
such worship of the intellectual is rare
Hutchinson teaches with superbly clear
lectures leveled at the top of the class
but when numerous anecdotes which keep
the rest of the class at least long in
spirit Hutchinson balances a complete
personal humility with a scorching
criticism of scientific work in the
literature which serves to teach the
student by example the difference
between good and bad research he's
immensely kind but also immensely
immersed science and ideas are his
interest he is also as impartial two
personalities and creates of his
students as is conceivably possible a
great person thank you very much for
that Nancy
I know it's it's it's a real challenge
to compress such a long life into a talk
and and you've done a wonderful job of
that thank you I'd like to introduce the
next speaker David's Kelly who as I
mentioned earlier is one of the
co-editors of the book the art of
ecology just to briefly explain how the
book came about and why they picked the
papers they've done so they should just
go for another hour or so no I'm just
going to speak for a few minutes my my
doctoral advisor Earl Warner has few
regrets about his graduate career but
one of the ones that he expressed to me
is that he finished his dissertation six
months too late to be on that tree that
was shown in Nancy's talk I think Nancy
set up the challenge for a group of
people to put together an anthology of
someone who made this this range of
contributions and I'm up here on behalf
of a group of people David post fellow
editor who is here Melinda Smith who is
not here with us today and a set of
contributors both to the volume I think
Michael Donahue in addition to the
people I've just mentioned Michael
Donahue and Jane Pickering are with us
today there were a couple of others
including Nancy and Sharon kingsland who
was shown in the talk here and also a
set of folks who came to give
presentations at that centenary
symposium that really kind of set the
tone and really the challenge and and
rather than go through the ideas and the
systems and so on Nancy's done a great
job of that I want to leave you just
with with one thing that I think
transcends all of Hutchinson's work I
think David and I share a sense of
humility in the job that we were given
to put together an anthology for someone
like this David never met hutchinson I
never met him Melinda Smith never met
him but in a sense we represent kind of
a handoff to the future all of us had
experiences as graduate students and
afterwards where we learned about
Hutchinson's ideas and the importance of
them
and my sense has been over the 15 years
that I've been at Yale that it has been
harder and harder for students to come
by that that sense of what Hutchinson
offered and so this to us who unlike
many of you were not friends with
Hutchinson don't remember him as a warm
human being but really it comes down to
the ideas it's the utility of the ideas
what do they do for us going into the
future and I think all of us shared the
sense that the famous papers that Nancy
showed still have something to offer but
what is really remarkable is what
happens when you go beyond the papers
that are still taught in classical
ecology type seminars and so on digging
in to what this one person was able to
accomplish is both humbling but it's
also enormously inspiring and just to
kind of cap it off I think what has been
most influential to me and this goes
back to really the first year when I was
studying ecology with with Earl who had
been deeply influenced by Hutchinson and
had me read a bunch of his papers was
the fact that Hutchinson had a very
particular approach that was really
based on observation this natural
history tradition that Hutchinson was
born into wasn't just a pastime where
you put on your your suit and tie and
you went out with your little net and
collected things on Sunday it was a way
of encountering the world and learning
about it and it wasn't just that you put
stuff into the jars and said job done
but you thought about what you'd found
very deeply and critically and you come
up with ideas and then you batter on
those ideas really hard you're tough on
them and in that I think he shared a
very close similarity with Darwin Darwin
was his own toughest critic who worked
in a very similar manner collecting
observations over a long period of time
sifting them grinding them up and seeing
what was stood his own tough critique
Hutchinson's ideas the niche ideas even
the limiting similarity ideas have
evolved themselves into enduring
concepts and
ecology so the 1.3 thing per se didn't
work out perhaps but the idea that
competition is an ongoing force that
shapes phenotypes out there and other
interactions are doing the same has had
a vibrant life and continues to have a
vibrant life the seeds of metapopulation
theory and a whole bunch of other ideas
that have taken on their own lives are
there and they come from Hutchinson and
the reason you know he thought about so
many different things but I think one of
the things to walk away from and to
explore both in Nancy's book and in the
anthology is that this is someone who
was so successful because he started
with things that were true things that
were real these weren't convenient ideas
they weren't ideas that came out of
Hutchinson's values even though he cared
about environmental issues and so on
there were things that he couldn't
discard that he couldn't ignore and I
think that some of that kind of thinking
could really help us today negotiate the
challenges that we have rather than
wishing things were one way or the other
being tough on those ideas and taking
them forward Thanks
I'd like to now call on leo bus to give
some insights into what I think would be
a very intimidating thing is to be a new
starting ecology professor in Hutchinson
shadow at Yale so I came to yell 1979
evilyn retired in 71 so he was like
emeritus for a decade by the time I
showed up I was in the same location I
am now evilyn was across know the
geography that's uh where we're gonna is
now even when for the entire last decade
of his life was being driven almost
exclusively by listening to the clock
tick he was trying to get the forest
volume of the treat is done and it was
clear that that wasn't going to happen
and that's what he thought about when he
woke up in the morning that's what he
did as much as he could all day long I
think he already knew by the time that I
came that the treatise was not going to
get done he he was working on the
benthos and the benthos was farthest
from his area of expertise I think he
was sort of shocked by the scope of the
benthos when he won when he got into it
and had already laid out what he wanted
to do in that volume and it was more
than you know a decade-long it was it
was a monumental task not only was it a
monumental task but at the time I
arrived he was laboring under the
advanced stages of Margaret's
Alzheimer's and so he couldn't
effectively couldn't do any work her
doctor had told him that she was doing
as well as she was because of the the
loving care he was given
and those of us who knew Hutchinson knew
that that was the death knell as soon as
he heard that he was going to be there
every single day and he wasn't going to
take any help and that's exactly what
happened all the way to the end he came
in every day but only for like an hour
or two and there were there were crazy
masa nations to get him that hour or two
so sarin Twombly who was his real last
student he had a lot of last students
but the real last one Sarah and Twombly
she would just should have show up you
know for a visit to Evelyn's house and
Margaret would know what was going on
right but within 15 minutes Margaret
forgot what was going on and so sarin
could in fact be visiting and even
though I can go off to the library for
an hour or two but even then of course
he was getting next to nothing done
because he was keeping the house he was
preparing the food and he was dealing
with someone who really wasn't there
anymore that was true for the first
several years that I was here and and
interacted closely with him when
Margaret died which was I don't know 82
83 something like that there there was a
period of four or five years where
evilyn could really get to work and he
did get to work he was there every day
all day long and he was working
essentially exclusively on the treatise
and he was increasingly a happy guy you
know he was he was enjoying what he was
doing but he was also there was also
this you know this the sense that that
that only increased in intensity that he
wasn't getting it done at the right rate
right at that time I spent a lot of time
with him partly because he just needed
help but but also because you know for
whatever reason we just got along
and uh and get to some sense of sort of
you know what his life was at that time
he was he was really he was he was sort
of a loner you know he he he didn't seek
people out he had no close interactions
with his colleagues the only people and
then biology department who interacted
with him it all really was Willard
Hartman his former student occasionally
league Luigi prova solely would come by
but very few interactions with his
colleagues and he didn't precipitate it
I I think he was you know basically in
some ways a fundamentally shy guy but
just you know a wonderfully warm guy if
you got anywhere close to his sphere of
influence but you had to bump into him
he wasn't going to bump into you he was
not only did he not become active not
not only did a lot of the his colleagues
in biology not interact with him he was
like completely emotionally decoupled
from what was going on in the department
at the time and some of you may remember
this was a time when ecology as a field
was going through wild fluctuations at
Yale and he was not in any material way
involved in that process nor was he in
any material way emotionally involved in
that process so this he was bit of a
loner but he was he wasn't a lonely guy
not at all he had a number of close
friends here you know Katherine Skinner
for example Luigi prova solely Willard
Hartman he had very close relationships
with a couple of students tandra shootin
Janie wolf sarin Twombly and he had
continuing series of visitors from his
mostly as former students that just lit
him up you know when Tom came you could
tell when Tom was coming he just lit up
like a light bulb 1.com tom was coming
the same was true with donna haraway the
same was true with Karen Porter some for
some of you in the audience you know it
you know these these peoples names and
these people came on a very periodic
sort of basis they were not like rare
visitors so he was by no means lonely
and he would then of course the besieged
by supplicants who would want to come
and meet the great man and so although
he was not you know materially involved
with people in you know the local
intellectual community the building if
you will every seminar speaker who came
through just absolutely had it you know
meet Hutchinson right and of course he
he was just totally unfailingly gracious
and wonderful with these people even
though he really wanted to get back to
work on the treatment there was no
question about that and so people would
come to his office and he you know he'd
have this sort of characteristic way of
of meeting them he'd say I don't have
any idea of what you do and I hope that
you'll tell me about it okay and you
know we're sitting in the back of the
lab going yet and I wish you would go
away but you'd never hear and of course
they felt so welcome and they'd start
you know an outpouring and sometimes
they were interesting and they were and
they were spewing Natural History and
evil and got into it more often than not
there was us you know there was some
component of idolatry to the
conversation and he just didn't have any
time for that and so he tended to cut
those conversations off very shortly but
not in sort of a convention
no way you know when you're having a
conversation with somebody that sort of
free-flowing you might just you know
something may come to your mind and
you'll say you know you know that thing
you said made me think about X right and
X has got nothing to do with anything
even would just say X you wouldn't do
not you do know preamble right so he
come out with his stupid non sequitur
right and then the person would sort of
pause because they didn't what's going
on here and then evilyn would get up if
even got up that meant the conversation
was over all right because he'd get up
and he said shamble his way up and he'd
reached out his hand and then these
people would go away and study the
comment that the evil and made a great
length looking for you know some some
you know profundity there and it just
wasn't there yet anyway uh I remember a
lot of my interactions with him I
studied competition when I first came to
Yale and so we've talked a lot about
competition because that was the way he
thought about ecological problems and I
studied with jeremy jackson who's in the
audience and we studied these things
that grew in two dimensions as sheets
think about lichens on a tree that
interacted in their margins and so evil
and just love that because evil and
didn't think about competition that way
for you know i'm going to drop
occasionally into code here but the
ecologist might find it useful in the
audience he thought about competition as
an exploitative process okay he thought
about the equilibrium solutions to the
lock to volterra equations as being the
only evolutionary outcome or the primary
evolutionary outcome of competition and
that led to all the ideas about limiting
similarity niche partitioning and all
the like alright but this was of course
a story about interference competition
and it was a story primarily about
alternative evolutionary outcomes
basically getting good at one thing
versus another just as long as your
environment
guaranteed to both things were around
and so evilyn just you know soft up that
natural history at no end and
immediately appreciate like immediately
appreciated that in the systems that
that that that I was working on you
could ask questions about the community
consequences of competition that were
completely distinct from the
intellectual tradition that that he had
spawned and he left he just loved that
when he when he loves something he'd say
more you know the marvelous I can't do
it I can't do that you can you do this
so you have to do the arboles for me and
uh but and so in some ways he was just a
delight to talk with in otherwise he was
like totally inaccessible I remember
being like completely confused with hit
with reactions that he had to uh
discussions about the current state of
ecology so he could not be engaged in
any meaningful way in sort of what was
happening to the ideas that he had
generated and how they were being
systematically dismantled and
misinterpreted and just done wrong you
know he just couldn't be interested in
this stuff in as far as he was concerned
there was competitive exclusion and if
there were predators that were keeping
densities solo the competition didn't
happen that was just another way in
which competitive exclusion was
suppressed it went click you could hear
go into the file cabinet in his head you
know everything got organized he put it
where it belonged rather than so you
couldn't engage in Hmong on the notion
that hey wait maybe communities are
getting controlled by top-down controls
that are fundamentally different and
maybe all that stuff you wrote didn't
make a whole lot of difference he wasn't
interested in that and I couldn't get it
I just could not get how this guy could
be so emotional
Leedy couple from the fate of his ideas
but of course you know of course that
was about you know I was 25 right I'm
pretty emotionally discovered
disconnected to what I did when I was 25
to so it's not too surprising a comment
about evilyn and women ah he was busy
unless you were a woman if you were a
woman Evelyn was spend as much time with
you as you would like I remember
graduate students and faculty and our
department coming to talk to me about
why evilyn wouldn't talk to them you
know you know he talks to her it the guy
was funny he was like any woman he would
talk to for any length of time and he
was an incredible flirt and he loved to
be flirted with right uh today he would
be in trouble if he was on the faculty
at Yale but he was an enormously a
supportive for those people that he was
close to he he would do anything and I
look back on my career I you know I
never let asked him for a letter or
anything I had you know any of that kind
of need for him but later I learned that
even was doing things to facilitate my
career that I knew nothing about and
this is at a time when he had you know
better things to be doing and so I can
easily see how you know that that tree
ramified people who are that successful
at mentoring that's never a mistake
ah just a few more words the first part
of the time I met him he was having
great difficulty with Margaret and doing
nothing but giving the end of his life
hasn't been mentioned here and that was
even more difficult his third marriage
was to a woman named and who proved
ultimately to be a alcoholic and the
time period from about nineteen eighty
eighty seven maybe tomm 88 certainly to
90 when his own health problems started
to kick in in a very major way started
getting transient episodes or little
strokes and the like they were
extraordinarily difficult I didn't know
what was going on at the time but I knew
something was going on because evil and
would show up at the office disheveled
and even was evil and was never to
shoveled he would show up with bruises
and he would show up with little cuts
and that would be okay you know people
of that age you know you know frequently
you know run into things and cut
themselves and stuff but they weren't
dressed cuts you know something was
wrong and for that last several years I
i frequently walked him home to canter
street from oml because there was nobody
takin care of them and you know you he
would if I was leaving and he wasn't uh
and he was still there I walked him home
and as soon as we would get close to
kannur street he would get increasingly
sort of uncomfortable and I had you know
had I knew at the time there was
something wrong here something was you
know fundamentally not
right and one of my greatest regrets in
life is I didn't do anything about it
you know I knew something was wrong but
I didn't think you know I had any
business going inside that door and
finding out what it was but ultimately
the end of his life was as difficult as
the period he was going through when
when I first came he had in that decade
when I knew him a central three or four
or five really good years bookend by you
know really fairly profound misery and
the last thought I want you to leave you
with about evilyn was that he never
never once complained never once said
anything that was anything less than
completely gracious including about the
two women that were the bookends thank
and last but not least Tom the floor is
yours so it is late and I will not to
take a lot of time but I was asked to
just sort of give my impressions of what
it was like to be one of those very
lucky people to be one of evil and
students and here is here's a man is
capable of producing these grand
syntheses and these huge volumes but at
the same time was famous for what today
we would call the soundbite so i was
thinking what would be the sound bite
for eve one that he was wise kindly
incandescent lee brilliant and a
veritable ecological Dumbledore because
you could ask him about anything and you
would get a really interesting answer
and his friends included people like art
history professor George Kubler who
worked on all the wonderful
archaeological things in the Yucatan and
they work together on the hypothesis
that hi there have been ecological
overreach and use of the land ha and so
that was one of the great joys of being
a student because anything could come up
and something very interesting and often
profound would be said
seems to me an obvious one of his
characteristics that he really had an
eye for talent and intellectual talent
and not just in science but I remember
he was one of the very first who
identified Robert many when he showed up
at the Institute for Advanced Studies at
Princeton as an extraordinary figure who
would be contributing in really
important ways to ecological science in
virtually within weeks of Leo appearing
at Yale I remember evil and say you must
talk to Leo bus and so it never occurred
to me until this morning thinking about
what I might say that the fact that that
Robert May and Leo bus were on the first
visiting committee I put together for my
forest fragments project was yet another
contribution from evilyn and we heard
from David in particular that but also
in the way Leo talked about the file
cabinet in Evelyn's mind that theory in
and Natural History had to fit together
and if the theory didn't fit the facts
in nature well then it was something
wrong with the theory because nature was
real and so he sort of looked at
everything in terms of frameworks of
understanding and I remember talking to
him when I was towards the end of my
thesis and had sort of discovered that
an always different forests and forest
gradients i was looking at in the amazon
that the most abundant bird species were
the same once and all these difference
that you
and even said oh he said that's part of
that a larger problem why two
communities are so similar that you find
the same species in the same number but
at the other end of the spectrum you
don't expect to find rotifers in the
desert or drafts on the bottom of the
sea I so that was the way he always
thought about things and one of his
other favorite phrases about some
particular piece of natural history
would be most peculiar and he had real
interest for the most peculiar because
those in fact were the ones that would
really test the theory so and I actually
remember i had the delight of going to
cambridge and see him get his honorary
degree and then flew back with him to
kennedy and we're in the front row of
economy and there's this movie screen
right in front of us with of all things
pop I you know this is all this stuff
going on you can't ignore it it's right
in front of your eyes and he looks up
and says most peculiar
so the other thing as I think about it
is it just one of the treats about being
one of his students was being with all
the other of his students who could be
studying anything from mosses to coral
reefs or or biogeochemical cycles or
Claude asura and I don't remember
anything other than a feeling of joy of
being part of that community I think
everybody felt that and he he just made
you be better than you otherwise would
be because he just wanted to hear that
word marvelous and you worked hard
enough that you could get there uh-huh
so I leave you with one one story I was
somewhere with Gerardo Badowski who was
a graduate of the forestry school and it
would take in one course in population
ecology with evil one and when he
discovered that I had the honor to be
evil and student he said you know my
head is still full of him and I think
that's true for every one of his
students and many of us in this room
thank
huh
just just real quickly one of the
reasons why we're here today is because
of the passion and endurance of some
unsung hero sort of in this in this
process of actually getting the books
from the writing stage the assembly
stage to the publication stage and just
really quickly we all just give a hand
of thanks to gene black who really was
largely responsible for making sure that
these books got published and and and
got the word out so thank you very much
gene for your heart
you